doctor's alert Donald Trump says he
expects to be indicted Again by special
counsel Jack Smith just moments ago the
former president writing on Truth social
this I hear that deranged Jack Smith in
order to interfere with the presidential
election of 2024 will be putting out yet
another fake indictment of your favorite
President me at 5 PM why didn't they do
this two and a half years ago why did
they wait so long because they wanted to
put it right in the middle of my
campaign prosecutorial misconduct
unquote the grand jury who will decide
on whether or not to indict Trump over
alleged election interference they met
earlier today so Griff Jenkins he's
outside the D.C courthouse where they
were meeting and Griff can you give us
your report what did you see
hey Dana good afternoon and obviously
that social post was made by the former
president at 441 and saying that there
was going to be this five o'clock news
we have not yet seen that but we have
been watching here outside the
courthouse all day long about whether or
not we could see indictments come and
the security around this Courthouse did
pick up noticeably the first thing we
noticed this morning when we came here
Dana was the Federal Protective Service
put some patrol cars out in front of the
courthouse still here behind me the
grand jury as you mentioned came and met
today slowly they trickled all afternoon
out we believe it appears they're gone
for the day so we're really watching and
waiting but if you go back to when we
first began to really watch closely it
was when that Target letter on July 16th
went to Trump's attorneys our sources
telling us in that Target letter there
were about three areas that the source
said that the president could possibly
be charged on one was deprivation of
fights under color of law pertaining to
civil rights charges of sorts along with
the conspiracy to commit offense or
defraud the U.S in a third area of
charges that could include witness
tampering we don't know if there's even
going to be an indictment or what's in
there this is just what we know was the
nature of the target letter which as you
know typically leads us to a possible
indictment now we were really on high
alert last Thursday out here because we
knew that Trump's attorneys met with
Jack Smith and his council at Jack
Smith's office nothing came Thursday
afternoon Friday over the weekend now
here we are on Tuesday afternoon with
the former president saying he expects a
press conference that will make an
announcement of these indictment charges
we can't confirm that we're just
watching and waiting Dana okay thank you
for setting this stage for us let's get
to David spun he's at the Department of
Justice we're going to talk to you and
then we'll take it around the table here
hi David hi Dana hi everyone listen we
are waiting for some sense of news from
the Department of Justice nothing from
special counsel Jack Smith who's
obviously attached to the Department of
Justice waiting to get that information
but if the former president is correct
and he is indicted this would mark his
third indictment and there could
possibly be a fourth indictment that's
down in Georgia that's a state charge
being run by the Fulton County
prosecutor fonnie Willis she's gone on
the record Dana and everyone at the
table multiple times in fact giving a
television interview recently saying
that her office is ready to go that
would be a that's an investigation
relating to the conversation that the
former president had on the phone on
tape with Brad raffensberger the Georgia
Secretary of State shortly after the
election saying that he needed
raffensberger to find some 11
000 votes so we're looking to see what
happens here with Jack Smith to see if
the former president is indeed indicted
as he says and we're also looking to see
what happens in Georgia in the next few
weeks Willis has gone on the record to
say that everything would be done
whatever everything means by September
4th so right now we watch and we wait
but clearly clearly there is news
Brewing on both fronts Dana Davis one
thank you and interesting Jesse
president Trump is so media Adept and so
it's interesting to watch like you can
put out a little post or a little tweet
whatever it is our little whatever
whatever method he's using and the media
runs to it this does seem like it might
be happening
perhaps tonight he's front running it we
don't know anything I don't know where
Jack Smith is we were said he was
supposed to come out at five I don't
know where he is
I don't know
if you don't think this is political
look at this on March 17th Hunter
accidentally admits his laptop is his
the day after Trump gets a notice that
he's going to be indicted June 8th the
FBI document drops that Biden took a
five million dollar bribe the next day
June 9th Mar-A-Lago indictment July 31st
Evan Archer testifies that Joe is on the
phone with the hunter business partners
one day later August 1st Trump January
6th indictment so this is all
coordinated I've looked at these charges
they said they're going to hit them with
one of these charges is conspiracy to
make a false statement
it's a crime for a government official
to make a false statement when they knew
the statement was false
I mean everyone in the government lies
so I don't know how you can charge that
obstruction of an official proceeding
remember the January 6 situation they
delayed the certification for a couple
hours so that means when code pink
disrupts a hearing you could get hit
with obstructing an official proceeding
okay then you have witness tampering
this says it is illegal to contact
anybody before they testify before
Congress
you're saying the Democrats never talk
to any witness before they testified in
front of a congressional hearing come on
these other charges I don't know
deprivation of Rights I don't know that
looks like a a very uh warped charge
conspiracy to defraud we'll see what
they come out with who knows I do know
Trump's tied with Biden New York Times
pull out they're both tied how are you
trying to throw your opponent in prison
and you still don't have a lead how is
that possible and Joe Biden's at 39
greatest economy in the world and he's
tied now if Biden is tied with Donald
Trump statistically he loses the
election Joe Biden or any Democrat has
to be ahead of Donald Trump a republican
by at least two to three percentage
points nationally because of the
Electoral College so he loses right now
Donald Trump is currently winning this
election if it was held today according
to the New York Times now what's going
to happen is you're going to have
impeachment I believe you're going to
have the inquiry in the fall you're
going to have impeachment going into
contrasted against Trump's federal court
cases in 2024. so both guys are going to
be going haywire and you know the
American people are going to be lawyers
are going to make a lot of money of
course they always do you know how I
feel about work I know how you feel
Jessica how did the Democrats take that
New York Times poll today that showed
43-43 tied Biden Trump well we wet the
bed as is our practice
um I I think it's important so first of
all there are a bunch of other polls
that do have tightened up now he used to
be down in the Real Clear Politics
average now he's up on average
um but the New York Times Santa poll is
a very reputable poll and it had a lot
of components to it that are quite
startling for Democrats like the gains
that Trump has made amongst black voters
black men I should point out not black
women and with Latinos the edge for Joe
Biden was basically nil right it was
three points I think
now this happens frequently we talked
about this going into the midterms there
was all that discussion you know the
Democrats are going to lose Latino
voters and then that isn't what happened
at all but you have to play every day
like it's the most important day of your
life you can't take any constituency for
granted nobody's doing at the beach no
that's not I
I would like one too
um just a little bit about the
indictment though
um listening to what Jesse said I I
completely understand the fact that
there are a lot of people who feel that
way when you look at the fact that Trump
is tied with Biden right now and he's
you know quad dieted by middle of August
we'd expect
um
well that's what we're calling I don't
know what else to say
um but there are
some incredibly important facts that
have come out about the January 6 case
Steve Bannon is on tape talking before
the election about how they're going to
act as if Trump won it before he even
knows what's going to happen you have
Peter Navarro who goes on TV bragging
about this he even wrote a book about
how Steve Bannon has orchestrated the
whole thing and it's like a football
team and that he's the quarterback I
think they were the Green Bay Packers I
guess maybe he's from there
um
that's disturbing and deprivation of
Rights is about nullifying people's
constitutional right to be able to vote
and have their vote counted and this
idea of minimizing January 6 down to uh
code pink screaming about abortion
rights or whatever in the atrium and
what happened on January 6th is not
going to fly with a majority of
Americans the FBI the FBI deprived
people of rights when they covered up
the laptop or the CIA what are you to
finagle the laptop you know what I'm
talking about that's corruption before
the election how that denies having a
story a New York Post story taken down
for 24 hours and what happened on
January 6th are so utterly incomparable
I'm actually shocked at you would have
changed
uh Greg we we actually don't know if
there's going to be a prescotts we don't
know if there's going to be an
indictment but I mean something's going
on it's just like old times right you
have slow news and all of a sudden Trump
tweets or in this case truths and we got
an A block if they're not careful they
will re-elect Trump I swear I mean if
Trump or Popeye indictments and
impeachments they're the spinach uh I I
know that you said that what happened on
January 6 is disturbing but disturbing
isn't illegal if it were I would get the
chair but I mean there's nothing I think
for me there's nothing that will ever be
more offensive disturbing than the riots
you know the antifa riots and the BLM
riots and we got nothing so I think that
that's why the indictments
on Trump and the impeachments they feel
like a process a political prosecution a
political persecution and that's why it
makes them stronger it's going to make
him even more of a folk hero than he
already is and like uh um Jesse says I
mean the timing is always so convenient
you know it's in the re and it's just a
coincidence of course because um but the
test rates one question why do all the
coincidences only break in One Direction
like there's never it's like something
good happens to something bad happens to
the uh Democrats and the you know and
then then somebody saves them that never
happens to the Republicans right they
never it never breaks in the direction
uh it only goes in One Direction in one
way we investigate and punish
Republicans and you take it if the
Republicans try to investigate a
Democrat you still get punished and you
will take it and now I mean what
politics is it's lawyers versus lawyers
yeah this is what politics is now
there's no I don't even know you don't
need pollsters anymore you don't need
anybody you don't need votes just put
the lawyers against the lawyers so now
you hope your team Republicans Or
democrats have the best lawyers so they
can go after the other guy but it feels
like the Republicans don't never feels
like they have the best lawyers in this
it's like they got them off the Clinton
impeachment they well that was a long
time ago well but those guys are still
around that's Bill Barr and all the
elves now they're on the Supreme Court
that's where they went that's why the
Republicans don't have any good lawyers
they're all in the Supreme Court
they feel like yeah that was well that
that was a great that was a great day
for all of us and unborn children
Jessica Katie the one thing that that
does is um it does keep the indictments
and so even with the coincidences which
are really interesting and I'm glad you
pointed that out because I often believe
that the government gets credit for
being created or being um really good
and competent at what they do and that
usually is just a coincidence but those
three right in a row uh that is pretty
telling uh but I also the other thing is
you don't have many people who are
neutral on Trump or Biden right they are
now in the New York Times are saying
okay it's 43 43 and you've got this
small little bit of Independence who are
persuadable on either side but the other
thing this does is make sure that
um the thing that people care the most
about which is their pocketbook and
their being nickeled and dimed to death
by all of these little regulations and
the taxes and they're just feeling like
they're suppressed of economically they
don't believe that biodynamics is
working for them but we aren't really
talking about any sort of economic plan
Ron DeSantis put when I yesterday was
like a 10-point plan it was like poof
Into The Ether but that's why the media
loves us though because it keeps Trump
in the news with the indictments and it
allows Biden to be at the beach while
his team touts bionomics on Twitter and
acts like that's working if you look at
the year ahead in the election it is
election interference I mean this is
going to change the election this will
be an election that we've never seen
before you know there's talk about
Donald Trump being pulled off the
campaign Trail but he's going to have to
be fighting one of these many
indictments in court and it looks pretty
fishy and smells when the president of
the United States has a department of
justice that continues to indict
President Joe Biden's top political
opponent on these charges and look
there's a big difference between a grand
jury returning an indictment it doesn't
have to be unanimous and that the
prosecutor Senate doj having to come
back and prove these cases Beyond A
Reasonable Doubt the reason there is so
much skepticism about these indictments
is because the justice department does
not have a good track record when it
comes to going after Donald Trump
whether it was a special counsel the
Russia collusion I mean for years on end
and when it comes to the American people
looking at this and and president Trump
becoming more popular in the GOP Primary
but just normal people the majority
actually think that the federal
government is far too powerful yep and
if you can't get something to stick and
you continue to run someone like Trump
through the ringer without actually
having anything people lose faith in
their institutions and this does not do
anything yes
the lack of trust in institutions yeah
and the death of norms as well I want to
Brian Kilmeade I want you to do me a
favor I want you to click to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page this is the
only way that I know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on Fox
you can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now